so hallo leute ja jetzt noch ich habe mir gedacht so eine stunde geht noch
radiantracer und der dr.bronups dankeschön für die Pogsubscriptions
ich muss gerade noch meinen vorschau rechner anmachen weil dem ist gerade
aufgefallen dass es eine neue chrome version gibt und als er versucht hat die
chrome version zu updaten hat er festgestellt ups die festplatte ist ja
voll warum auch immer ich mache auf dem rechner eigentlich gar nix
die war wahrscheinlich schon die ganze zeit nahezu voll und jetzt ist sie
komplett voll ich muss übrigens ein bisschen hören ob das handy klingelt
weil ich muss auf monitor meldungen von der arbeit gucken falls da irgendwas
kommt glücklicherweise kommt da immer nur sehr selten was
jetzt der vorschau rechner auch am start
ich muss mal was trinken eigentlich hab hier muss man kurz was einschränken
glaube ich heute recht wenig getrunken hast du gewisse benefits erst nach der
probezeit nutzen können hast du ja habe ich aber ganz ehrlich das benutze ich
für nichts außer für dienstgramm das ist ein iphone was ist das für eins das
ist noch ein iphone was keine drei kameras hinten hat wahrscheinlich ein
zwölfer vermutlich 10 oder wartet mal nach ich weiß keine iphone ich weiß
nicht ist doch so etwas schmaleres iphone mit nur zwei kameras hinten
ne das sind diese ganz flachen kameras nicht diese dicken sondern so viel wo
sieht man dann was es für ein iphone ist kann man das in den system settings
irgendwo sehen so allgemein info ein iphone 12 ist das ein iphone 12 aber ich
benutze das für nichts wirklich ich habe da nichts privates drauf weil das habe
ich mir beim letzten also beim wechsel auch auch überlegt das war eines der
probleme die ich hatte als gewechselt bin von der alten arbeit zu dahin da
wollte ich ja die handynummer mitnehmen und das war ein bisschen größere akt
und ich habe mir vorgenommen ich werde kein diensthandy mehr privat benutzen
da gibt es einfach viel weniger probleme also also nicht dass sie die firma
probleme macht sondern für dich selbst gibt es weniger probleme muss keine
nummer umziehen du musst dir nicht gedanken machen ob die app jetzt
dienstlich oder privat benutzt wird gerade bei office ist das ist das
kompliziert du weißt welches handy klingelt dann ist es auch das für die
also ich finde es einfach angenehmer ich habe zwei handys dabei bei mir auf der
arbeit gibt es viele die schwören darauf nur das diensthandy mitzunehmen
immer über die haben gar kein privates mehr und habe ich auch schon gesagt ja
da bin ich schon durch macht es absichtlich so ich renne jetzt halt
immer mit zwei handys rum ich werde ich werde im im zug teilweise
übelst blöd angeguckt weil im zug kommt es manchmal vor weil ich ja erst von der
arbeit weg bin dass noch ein paar teams messages kommen oder sowas und da muss
ich immer iphones dual wielden im im zug also mein privates weil ich da halt
gerade gucke auf reddit oder irgendwas auf youtube laufen habe irgendwie guckt
mir halt was an und dann höre ich halt dann höre ich halt eine message oder
merkst dass im rucksack vibriert dann mache ich halt noch mal auf und holt
das handy daraus da muss ich dann zwei iphones dual wielden und die denken
wahrscheinlich im zug alter guckt dir mal den kack angeber an man muss uns hier
alle auf die nase binden dass er sich voll krass findet weil er zwei iphones
apple akimbo sozusagen ja dual iphone models aber zum glück nicht 1887 oder
so warum weiß ich eigentlich noch dass diese dinger heute wird dass diese dinger
model 1887 hieß das ist 500 jahre her war mal kurz package update
die sind überhaupt so nicht dass ich mich jetzt übelst abfeier und das
stimmt überhaupt nicht ich ich mache heute kein rust leute
das das halte ich heute nicht aus wir können ja nicht ich wollte eigentlich
vorhin aber da wollte ich auch schon vor zwei stunden anfangen ein bisschen was
weitermachen aber das halte ich heute wirklich nicht aus
heute zehn sekunden für den scam train ich glaube nicht dass es was wird aber
macht ja nix muss ja hier keiner subscribieren wie es
mein englischlehrer gesagt hätte ist auch nice wenn ihr einfach nur am start
so machen wir mal die ganzen krempel zu package update pac-man ich ich use
archlinux by the way dachte mir ich erzähle euch das mal weil sich das für
einen ordentlichen archlinux user gehört dass er der welt mitteilt dass
er by the way archlinux verwendet ich habe früher mal gesagt es heißt
archlinux ist aber nicht so nix war ein kernelupdate oder irgendwas dabei in der
richtung trotzdem reboot immer reboot flip phone
ja kennt ihr noch diese alten motorola razor wo die ganzen leute die sich die
sich super super krass fanden ein goldenes motorola ne war das motorola
ja ich glaube goldenes razor phone hatten da gab es dann auch irgendwie die
razor dolce cabana edition und so ein stumpf sind was ich dann irgendwelche
wichtig tour gekauft haben und den ganzen tag damit dann rum standen und
dass die ganze zeit auf und zu geklappt haben so als sind sie halt super krass im
business und super super wichtig also im prinzip so ein bisschen wie kommen die
gruppe heute wo sie dann vorbeikommen mit einem fetten auto haben sie es halt
damals mit mit dem goldenen handy gemacht dabei waren die dinge so schrottig
man ich fand die überhaupt nicht geil so aber geschafft noch package package ist
ein bisschen up to date eigentlich hat es überhaupt keinen sinn dass ich
package updates gemacht habe aber ich dachte so weil warum nicht wenn wir
schon dabei sind hey hatte heute ein großzügiges anbekommen rpg zu
entwickeln sehr random oder war mit schulung und allem drum und dran gehalt
wäre nach zwei jahren bei 3.700 euro hätte ich das annehmen soll das kann ich
dir nicht sagen als erstes muss man natürlich wissen genau das kriegst du am
ende überwiesen das schwierig zu wissen im vorfeld ja brutto ist das jetzt nicht
so krass musst du überlegen also es sei denn die bezahlen 18 monatsgelder oder
was das ist nicht viel hätte sie nicht annehmen sollen es sei denn du möchtest
du möchtest unbedingt spiele entwickeln aber die leute rekrutieren doch nicht
einfach random leute als spieleentwickler wie kam das denn dazu
es ist doch nicht so dass ich heute sagt chat frosty gr wie sieht's aus
möchtest du spieleentwickler bei mir werden so einfach random zu irgendwelchen
auspicken oder war das was irgendwie linked in oder gar in deutschland ist
ja xing sehr beliebt warum eigentlich ich habe immer den eindruck link die
ganze welt verwendet linked in deutschland wird eigentlich auch linked
in verwendet aber irgendwie hält sich sing trotzdem hartnäckig wobei man sagen
muss link in ist eindeutig eher dass das sagen wir mal dass das ja so facebook
ist das falsche wort so dass das mir fällt gar kein vergleich dazu ein nicht
nicht das tiktok der der job aber jetzt social dinger zumindest es ist so oft
auf linkedin sind so diese ganzen möchte gern elon musks am start die dir dann so
was wie erzählen führen bedeutet für mich bla bla bla oder oder oder oder so
was oder die erzählen wir machen hier spitzen it und dann lobreisen sie sich
erst mal zwei seiten lang ja aber warum gehen die nicht einfach auf warum gehen
die nicht auch auf linkedin weil linkedin hauptsächlich it ist oder was
aber aber singt doch auch oder nicht ich kann es mir jetzt ich wenn ich glaube
nicht dass hier der lokale schreiner auf singen irgendwelche nachwuchskräfte
also ich habe ein linkedin profil das kennt ihr ja ich habe leider mein passwort dafür
nicht mehr das gibt es aber immer noch definitiv nicht fake dieses sing profil
und was ich was ich gemeinsame kontakte ansehen was zum teufel welche gemeinsamen
kontakte ich bin nicht mal eingeloggt ich kann überhaupt keine gemeinsamen kontakte
haben was sie was ein was eine tschibei plötzlich anzeige gemeinsame kontakte ansehen
ja ja genau hier das sind meine die ganzen entwickler grills alles meine kontakte ach
ne ich bin ja gar nicht eingeloggt kein fake profil ich habe leider ich echt das ich habe
es auch mit einer fake e-mail adresse verknüpft keine chance mehr da reinzukommen der ist
arbeitslos bei apple cloud native java bis bist du denn wenigstens hauptberuflich
java entwickler oder hast irgendwas in der richtung auf deinem profil stehen oder haben
sie einfach meist so guck mal der hat schon mal was programmiert möchte der nicht java
entwickler werden geschickt ist einer von euch check haben wir haben wir hauptberuflich java
entwickler am start und das muss ich hauptberuflich sein leute leute die die schon mal java zeug
entwickeln ein bisschen größeren stil du kennst ich kenne auch welche ich kann ja ich
kann kennen tue ich auch welche das stimmt ok sehr gut exzellent doch haben wir ja weil es
ist gar nicht so wenig verbreitet deswegen hat es mich jetzt auch gewundert wenn wir wenn wir
gar gar keine hätten ok teo ich habe eine frage an dich wenn du java entwickler bist ich habe den
eindruck dass also ich kenne ja auch von der von der alten arbeiten von der neuen arbeit bei java
entwickler ich habe den eindruck dass java entwickler irgendwie keinen bock haben sich
andere sachen außer java anzugucken ich meine letztendlich kannst du das wahrscheinlich auf
ganz vieles übertragen aber ich habe das schon gemerkt letztens hatte ich in java entwickler der
wollte kubernetes über maven installieren anstatt einfach binary ich meine es hatte vielleicht einen
sinn aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher warum man kann es auch irgendwie übertreiben also maven ist
irgendwie so ein package manager für java und so dependency manager muss man sagen eigentlich
wobei was ist maven für java eigentlich genau ich dachte dass es so sowas wie nugget so denn
so eine dependency manager package installer vielleicht weiß doch irgendjemand zumindest
ich habe den eindruck java entwickler haben irgendwie keinen bock irgendwas außer java
zu verwenden wie gesagt maven um binary packages aus dem internet runter zu laden und solche
geschichte wie gesagt ich habe das passwort nicht mehr ich kann ich kann nix annehmen
sätke okay ist das nicht so gut vielleicht kenne ich einfach nur die falschen java entwickler aber
ich habe diese also ich habe diese diese eigenschaft schon bei vielen java entwickler
gesehen am geilsten war mal einer der immer noch wie heißt das ding net net net beans gibt so was
net beans ja genau net beans ist moment gehört das oracle shit das gehört oracle ernsthaft
monkeys patchy was denn jetzt ist net beans ist net beans pack oder paints champ also ich weiß
es ist alt und auf der alten arbeit hatte ich einen entwickler der hat total geschwört auf
net beans in der schule ja ich habe net beans irgendwie vor 20 jahren oder so mal installiert
und dann nicht gewusst was ich mit machen soll wieder runter geschmissen übrigens chat weiß
ich ob ich es mitgekriegt habt welt 5 alpha ist raus wenn ich das ja noch richtig schreiben kann
vielleicht sollten wir uns das gleich mal angucken ich glaube wir gucken uns das gleich
wir gucken uns gleich mal an was new ins welt 5 alpha ist ich schreibe das mal kurz in die
stream themen aus in die stream themen auf ich kann heute schreiben welt ist ein javascript
framework also ein javascript framework von drei mehr gibt es ja nicht macht ja keiner
javascript frameworks gibt nur gibt nur drei stück ja okay wenn du note js mitzählst noch
4 4 vielleicht ja aber da muss man schon echt großzügig sein dass dafür gibt welt ist ein
javascript frontend framework wo du webseiten mitmachen kannst allerdings muss man da noch
dazu sagen es ist nicht nur webseiten also es ist eigentlich komplett full stack fähig
mittlerweile du kannst server side rendering machen du kannst frontend reine reine frontend
single page applications machen du kannst so hybrid sachen machen server side rendern hydraten
und auch im frontend fortsetzen du kannst api endpunkte mit javascript machen also kannst
eigentlich ins welt mittlerweile komplette webanwendung bauen backend und frontend mit
allem was man braucht ich persönlich mag das allerdings nicht den backend teil vielleicht
habe ich es einfach nicht genug benutzt aber ich bin kein großer javascript backend fan obwohl ich
javascript selbst eigentlich ziemlich mag mittlerweile javascript ist neben sie schafft
meine mittlerweile tatsächlich man glaubt es kaum zweitlieblings programmier sprache das liegt
daher liegt aber auch daran weil ruby niemand mehr verwendet denkt ihr es kommt irgendwann eine gute
alternative für javascript nein das sehe ich nicht javascript ist so omnipräsent mittlerweile im
browser umfeld auf dem desktop überall ich meine guck mal ein großteil der handy apps dürfte
javascript sein ein großteil der desktop sachen ist mittlerweile ja auch javascript guckt euch
an das konnte ich javascript mit einigen native extensions auf dem desktop die ganzen webseiten
das also ohne javascript geht es nicht mehr und javascript ist eigentlich zu groß um es auf
einen schlag zu ersetzen man muss allerdings sagen javascript muss auch überhaupt nicht
ersetzt werden weil javascript im vergleich zu sagen wir mal c++ einen echt ganz guten job
macht die sprache kontinuierlich sinnvoll zu ergänzen und weiterzuentwickeln nicht so wie
c++ wo man in den standard guckt und sich zum beispiel fragt was wollen die von mir überhaupt
zum beispiel du gehst dahin und willst dir willst du die features von c++ 23 angucken ich bin ich
bin noch nicht mal ich bin noch nicht mal in der lage diese komische webseite hier richtig zu
bedienen dass ich mir die features anzeigen lassen kann ja also keine ahnung ja hier ist hier steht
was es zum beispiel neues für c++ 23 gibt da steht an so sachen drinne wie ja das ist doch gar
nicht alles wenn die webseiten schon so schrottig sind man hat man schon wieder gar keinen bock
sondern hat man dann zum beispiel solche sachen das wollte ich euch nicht nicht zeigen ja da hast
du dann solche sachen wo sich irgendjemand gedacht hat alles klar jetzt jetzt ist ob wir es was hier
passiert finde es ist ganz ganz klar so logisch ich war und das ist noch leute und das ist noch
easy c++ templating was man hier sieht das geht noch viel viel krasser also ich meine nachdem ich
jetzt die letzten tage ein bisschen rast angeguckt habe muss ich sagen die rast syntax ist genauso
kacke nur mit dem unterschied dass rast noch in irgendeiner art und weise sinn ergibt ja also
wie gesagt du hast recht du hast recht ich meine eigentlich das weltkit ich ich verwende das
mittlerweile echt synonym ich glaube ich habe noch nie nicht das stimmt das ich habe noch nie
eine einzelne weltanwendung du hast vollkommen recht das vollsteck geschichte ist weltkit und
hat mit welt gar nichts so direkt zu tun also das eine ist nicht das andere aber ich mein
zwölf ja das stimmt so und deswegen das wird das wird nicht passieren aber das ist auch nicht
schlimm javascript ist mittlerweile wirklich ganz gut geworden natürlich hat javascript immer noch
so die üblichen dinger die die die also wie geht das wie war das ich krieg es ich krieg es aus dem
kopf gar nicht mehr hin ja ich habe es ich habe es wieder gefunden ja also als javascript hat schon
so ein paar komische dinger also hier kommt das raus das finde ich ist immer das beste beispiel
wie wird javascript letztendlich ist new array 5 join a minus allein schon diese diese ausdruck
ist halt schon komplett 4 a minus 10 aber letztendlich wenn man ein bisschen rein denkt
ist es ja eigentlich ganz logisch ja es ist ein array mit fünf slots ein leeres array mit fünf
mit fünf plätzen drin und dann joint man das also mit join macht man glaube ich aus dem array
einen string und gibt an man möchte als trennzeichen zwischen den nicht vorhandenen elementen zwischen
den fünf nicht vorhandenen elementen ein trennzeichen möchte man eben a minus 10 benutzen
a minus 10 ist allerdings not a number deswegen kommt fünf mal not a number und am ende wird das
ganze dann halt plus weil es ein string ist am ende plus Batman kommt das raus aber das ist für
mich immer das beste beispiel wie pega javascript immer noch ist aber nichtsdestotrotz javascript
hat halt so ein paar also auch diese sachen mit gleich gleich gleich und sowas javascript hat
ultra viel weird champiges zeug drinnen nichtsdestotrotz man kann das mittlerweile echt
ganz gut umschiffen und wenn man es nicht darauf anlegt es kaputt zu machen dann geht es in der
regel auch ganz gut auf der anderen seite muss man auch sagen dadurch also durch durch diese
super dynamische natur von javascript dass du auch überall eigene funktionen dran attachen
kannst und sowas ist das halt auch super nice da eigene library funktionen und so zu erstellen also
die ganzen frontend frameworks die wären mit ihrer zusätzlichen syntax wahrscheinlich in anderen
sprachen gar nicht so ohne weiteres möglich what the fuck javascript das kenne ich den den
konferenz talk kenne ich ja der ist top ja hier hast du ein paar hier hast du ein paar examples
ja das ist das ist auch geil das ist das ist das ist auch mega nice wobei ist das überhaupt das
was ich meine array is equal to not array obviously alles klar oder es ist halt schon
wird es ist halt auch ein bisschen problematisch dass es halt alles geht aber denkt dran ihr
wisst wie javascript entstanden ist javascript ist entstanden als netzcape ich bin mir gar nicht
so sicher ob es netzcape war als irgendein browser hersteller gesagt hat wir brauchen für eine neue
demo version von unserem browser irgendwas script bares du hast eine woche zeit und dann hat er oder
zwei oder 14 tage zeit oder sowas und da hat der javascript erfinder sich hingesetzt ach ja und
sie haben ihm dazu gesagt hau irgendwas rein am ende benutzt eh keiner wir brauchen das nur zu
demo zwecken so ist javascript entstanden also spricht der javascript erfinder hat irgendwie
in ein paar tagen was zusammengeknüppelt das wurde in browser gepackt und siehe da das dumme ist die
leute haben es verwendet und seitdem war es nicht mehr änderbar und du kannst das du kannst wisst
ihr das ist auch so eine frage die man sich dann immer stellt die man sich bei vielen technologien
stellt die halt sachen drinnen haben die nicht richtig durchdacht sind ja also das was ich euch
eben gezeigt habe das ist ja offensichtlich nicht richtig durchdacht dass so dinger möglich sind
in der sprache und dass das blöde ist halt man denkt sich so warum ändern die das nicht einfach
das problem ist halt es gibt website das gibt anwendung die verlassen sich darauf dass das
funktioniert und die würdest du auf einen schlag kaputt machen also du kannst quasi nie diesen
weird champ entfernen aus javascript das geht nicht weil du dann zig webseiten hast die die
kaputt gehen weil irgendwelche sonderverhalten nicht geht und deswegen kannst du halt auch in
vielen älteren sprachen sachen nicht einfach ändern man kann es aber versuchen sag mal sinnvoll zu
erweitern so wie das javascript macht dass manche alten konstrukte eben überflüssig werden zum
beispiel ja javascript bekommt jetzt eine neue date time api weil die alte kacke ist bisher haben
die leute immer sowas wie date fns verwendet als als live als zusätzliche library weil weil der
datesupport in javascript doof ist und jetzt gibt es javascript new date ich weiß gar nicht wie das
ich weiß gar nicht wie das neue zeug heißt schätze ihr javascript javascript 5 herz ja
temporal api genau can i use und das ist halt man kann es noch nicht noch nicht lösen aber die idee
finde ich halt ganz gut weil javascript jetzt nicht sagt okay wir machen das alte so noch mehr
wird zeug obendrauf und parallel neues wird zeug was genauso wie so wie c++ javascript sagt okay
die alte date time api ist vielleicht nicht so geil viele seiten verwenden die lasst sie mal da
und die kann man für einfache sachen verwenden aber hier habt ihr was neues ein bisschen besser
durchdacht ist also das finde ich finde ich eigentlich ganz sinnvoll wie die das machen
so gerade fernsehsensoren habe schon schelle geräte aber nix mit sick bmq t eingebaut gibt
es da ab und sensoren empfehlung ja ich kann hier ein paar empfehlen ist die frage für welche
technologie das hat du das haben willst ich habe tatsächlich noch ganz viele sie wave sensoren
weil ich damals als ich mit heimautomatisierung angefangen habe viel mit sie wave gebaut habe und
die dinge halten einfach ewig deswegen ist ich glaube ich habe die jetzt seit fünf jahren so
die batterie geht immer noch also das ist nice ansonsten was ganz gutes wenn du sick b haben
willst sind die kara sensoren die ganz klein musste da musste auch ein bisschen gucken weil
da gibt es irgendwie drei verschiedene versionen von sowie halt bei vielem china kram wo man nicht
richtig durchblickt ich glaube das ist der ganz alte oder der ganz neue man blickt da nicht so
genau das ist noch mal ein anderer was auch immer es gibt davon aber verschiedene versionen so
zumindest da brauchst du gar keinen hub da brauchst du einfach nur ein sick b stick ich habe ein konbi
ich würde aber heute kein konbi oder auch kein konbi zweimal kaufen ich würde mir heute wenn
ich was mit sick b mache einen mit diesem neuen chip drauf kaufen der der thread sick b und alles
kann so von sonoff zum beispiel der sonoff stick ist ganz gut mit dem mit dem neuen sick b chip
drauf ja also das da kannst du eigentlich nicht so viel verkehrt machen und manchmal hast du glück
manchmal gibt es bei aliexpress bei den chinesischen china chinesen gibt es manchmal
billiger aber man alter die seite sie einfach so krass nach scam aus ja und da hast du und da hast
du manchmal glück da kriegst du relativ günstig wie zum beispiel hier wobei das wahrscheinlich
nur einer ist ja siehst du okay das viel zu teuer aber wenn du mal guckst du kriegst manchmal
relativ günstig bei aliexpress davon einen größeren pack muss man muss immer man muss immer ein bisschen
gucken dass die ein nicht richtig zu bäten dass sie nicht eine hachi baden mit dem was sie da
anbieten und dafür kannst du natürlich den offiziellen hub verwenden aber ich finde den
offiziellen hub relativ sinnlos du brauchst ein sick b stick und den stepp stöpsel zu einer
home assistant oder halt an was auch immer dran und damit machst du das dann oder du nimmst sick
b to mqtt das gibt es auch das habe ich bei mir im einsatz das ist quasi so eine externe lösung
die dann über mqtt die den sick b state weiter schickt unterstützt meine erfahrung nachher die
meisten geräte und auch am fehlerfreisten also da gibt es auch eine gute gute home assistant
integration also das ding benutze ich gerade so sieht es aus ich schicke einfach javascript nicht
also wirklich durchzuplicken ist ja bei javascript nicht möglich das habe ich ja gerade gezeigt
verstehen tut das keiner aber du musst dich ja nicht im detail mit den ganz wirren sachen
auseinandersetzen benutzt javascript eigentlich normal dann lässt sich eigentlich ziemlich gut
gut verstehen und du hast einen riesen vorteil was javascript angeht es gibt für javascript glaube
ich so viele tutorials wie für nichts anderes mittlerweile gibt es auch noch sehr viel python
content auf youtube weil das so gerade die die ganze hipster in einer der hipster sprachen
schlechthin ist aber javascript tutorials und und überhaupt alles javascript ökosystem libraries
ich glaube es gibt keine sprache die so viele tutorials und videoserien und alles mögliche
hat wie javascript typescript ist ja jetzt ja es ist eine eigene sprache aber unter unterm
strich führt er dann browser nicht typescript aus wobei ich bei typescript auch sehr wehre
sachen schon gesehen habe ich habe letztens gesehen dass einer in typescript einen regex
parser nur in typescript templates programmiert hat ja weiß auch nicht was mit den leuten los
ist und dann du bist ruby und echt ich dachte es gibt es gibt so gut wie keine rails anwendung
mehr na gut es gibt bestimmt noch jede menge rails anwendung die aber halt mittlerweile sehr
legacy sind wahrscheinlich die hat noch supported werden müssen weil weil die leute sie benutzen
also mir fallen spontan fällt mir meine notiz app ein die ist in javascript prime video und
prime music ist wahrscheinlich zum größten teil auch javascript die amazon app ist javascript
die twitch app ist wahrscheinlich javascript die reddit app ist javascript discord ist javascript
gmail ist javascript meine krankenkasse app ist javascript lieferando ist javascript der
db strecken agent bin ich bin ich sicher ob der javascript ist die dhl app ist höchstwahrscheinlich
javascript also ich meine das war jetzt gefühlt 60 prozent der apps die ich auf meinem iphone
installiert habe javascript also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen dass wenige apps javascript ich würde
ganz ehrlich ich würde auch sofort eine mobile app am liebsten in javascript machen bevor ich
mit dart und flatter anfange wenn man dann irgendwelche super speziellen hardware also
iphone spezifischen sachen machen will oder vielleicht auch irgendwelche hardware video
decoder ansprechen möchte irgendwie es macht es macht sicherlich sinn auch in manchen fällen
was anderes zu benutzen als javascript aber so als default für eine app finde ich javascript echt
sinnvoll weil die meisten apps sind ja im endeffekt mehr oder weniger die webseiten verpackt in der
app bloß ein paar zusatzfunktionen was ist das denn massive jetzt stellen sich auch immer neues
zeug aus ja das stimmt es kommt übrigens demnächst müssen wir uns auch aufschreiben stream thema
dort hat acht gibt es ja auch ein paar ganz spannende neue sachen müssen wir uns auch aus
bringen weil dort hat acht ist jetzt bald soweit ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher das müsste doch
jetzt eigentlich sein ja genau jetzt ja genau ich wollte gerade sagen das ist doch jetzt
irgendwo und die angela werde ich nicht machen ja ist raus ach wo wir gerade dabei sind
dort nicht acht angela hat sich stark verbessert ich habe es gehört aber so stark verbessert kann
ich das gar nicht haben dass ich bock auf angela habe so wunderbar wir haben neues
am start wenn wir glück haben brauche ich das gar nicht mehr weil acht beide way auch
so nein die haben noch dort mit sieben dann warte ich noch mal bis die nate ich warte
bis es im offiziellen repo ist ich muss aber sagen dass ich einige der neuen features die
sich die letzten jahre über in c sharp eingeschlichen haben auch nicht so tolle finde
es gibt in c sharp mittlerweile auch einige doppeldeutige sachen zum beispiel gerade mit
dieser version das gucken wir uns dann auch zusammen an dieser dieser shortcut fürs definieren
von quasi so ich weiß gar nicht wie sie dieses nennt quasi den den constructor inline in der
definition schreiben das ist super wird weil sich das anders verhält zwischen strahlt classes
und records aber genau gleich aussieht aber was anderes mal also das ist das ist echt nicht nicht
so nice ja primary constructors ja genau das meine ich kotlin back end also wenn du in einer
sprache auf zack bist dann da kommst du doch auch mit javascript gut klar guck mal wir haben hier
im stream nummer so nämlich noch mal mich als vergleich ich bin weder hauptberuflicher entwickler
noch bin ich jetzt irgendwie der krasse frontend checker aber sogar wir haben im stream schon einige
durchaus denke ich war anspruchsvolle frontend projekte gebaut also ich finde immer noch eines
der geilsten sachen die wir je gemacht haben im stream und chat wird mich mal interessieren ob
ihr mir da mehr recht gibt eine der geilsten sachen die wir bisher im stream gemacht haben
war c++ ffmpeg web assembly kann sich daran erinnern wo wir einen video player gebaut haben
in c++ den zu web assembly kompiliert haben und im browser haben laufen lassen und dieser video
player konnte und das war der trick dabei dieser video player konnte formate abspielen dieser
browser gar nicht unterstützt du konntest damit zum beispiel im browser ts dateien abspielen ts
da sind so so alte dinger mit mpeg 2 drin wie man fernsehprogramm zum beispiel aufnimmt du
konntest damit im browser codex abspielen die der browser nicht unterstützt hat weil ffmpeg cross
compiled zu web assembly das umgewandelt hat und wir haben es gestreamt von einem webserver runter
das war er weiß ich ob da einer von euch dabei dabei war aber das war finde ich eines der geilsten
sachen die wir gemacht haben und wenn wir frontend geduld hier im stream auf die reihe kriegen und
du bist gut in kotlin backen da kriegst du das auch auf die reihe und wie du schon sagst man
kommt ja auch nicht dran vorbei was ist deine meinung zu rast im frontend mit web assembly
also meine meinung zu rast ist das rast viel zu kompliziert ist um darin irgendwas oder viel zu
anstrengend zu programmieren ist um darin irgendwas zu machen das nicht die stärken von rast zwingend
braucht und die stärken von rast sind speed plus halbwegs memory safety zur compile zeit für
sicherheitskritische anwendung und das ist ein ist eine browser anwendung nicht die läuft ja in
der browser sandbox und viele viele anwendungen sind es auch nicht also da muss ich tatsächlich
sagen von meiner web assembly experience hat mir bisher c++ am besten gefallen und das heißt was
ihr wisst wie geil ich c++ normalerweise finde und ich kenne ein gutes javascript framework in welchem
man also einfach simple ui erstellen kann also wenn du wirklich simple ui haben willst also
wirklich was was nicht über in der webseite mit zwei buttons die irgendwas machen und dann
reloaden und so weiter rausgeht dann brauchst du nichts großartiges zusätzliches als javascript
ansonsten nehmen einfach das weltkit c++ in verbindung mit web assembly ja das meine ich
ernst das war mir bisher echt am liebsten so vor den web assembly sachen was ich ausprobiert
habe ich finde c++ übelst kacke aber in dem fall war es ganz gut wir haben halt auch so ziemlich
alles ausgelassen was c++ bietet das nötigste genommen ja also guck dir das weltkit an das
weltkit ist echt easy du musst dich ja auch um nix gedacht also musst du um nix gedanken machen
solange das rein front und seitlich verwendet also sobald die website ein bisschen komplexer
ansonsten javascript css html ohne irgendwas wenn es wenn es eine seite ist mit drei buttons drauf
braucht man keinen kein frontend framework und wenn du willst dass es gut aussieht und einfach
brain dead irgendwie funktioniert und das 30 milliarden examples gibt neben bootstrap genau
das wollte ich auch gerade sagen daneben einfach bootstrap bootstrap ist zwar kein frame kein
kein frontend framework bootstrap bietet aber ziemlich viele fertigen interaktiven elemente
auch schon an die einfach einbinden kannst dann sieht eine seite halt aus wie die 0815 bootstrap
seite aber sieht ganz brauchbar aus und wenn du super advance bist stellst du einfach an den
bootstrap farben noch ein bisschen rum und dann erkennt auch keiner auf den ersten blick direkt
dass bootstrap ist angela und react also view zum einstieg ok aber angela und react würde ich würde
ich nicht unbedingt zum einstieg empfehlen wenn jemand eh schon keinen bock auf frontend
sachen hat hey max was hältst du so hey wo bloß was hältst du von headhuntern kommt noch wann
was es für welche sind wenn es die üblichen ich spamme alle auf linkedin und sing an sind
dann wenig aber wenn sie dir was gutes vorschlagen ist doch letztendlich nur gut für dich ganz
ehrlich mal reingucken was es ist schadet nix die erzählen dir aber halt sonst was ja weil
letztendlich die kriegen geld also für die lohnt sich nur wenn sie leute vermitteln und ein geld
abgreifen das heißt die erzählen dir das blaue vom himmel und die erzählen der gegenseite das
blaue vom himmel vom himmel also ich habe das schon erlebt dass headhunter und resi resi wie
spricht man das richtig aus resumes oder heißt das so wenn man das cool sagen will also lebensläufe
und skillisten im endeffekt geschickt haben die waren so krass getunt dass wir als der
bewerber dann da war und den was gefragt haben dass er darauf gesagt haben das hat er doch gar
nicht geschrieben und da hat ihm dann mein chef das gezeigt und da meinte er doch kommt mal da
steht drin keine ahnung fünf jahre jay boss erfahrung und er meint so einer das hat meine
recruiter da reingeschrieben ich habe mit jay boss außer keine ahnung ab install jam install nie
was gemacht wir hatten auch mal einen der hatte langjährige linux erfahrung und ist jetzt kein
spaß leute ich weiß das klingt so wie ausgedacht aber ich habe schon ein paar mal erzählt und das
das leute wir hatten wir hatten mal in so einer in so einem resume stehen langjährige linux
erfahrung ratet mal was der typ gemacht hat schon was die langjährige linux erfahrung war max fps
bester mann ja schön dass du hier gelandet bist wie hast du mich gefunden über youtube link oder
weil ich hier den gleichen den gleiche avatar habe ls ssh connection aufmacht nein nein nein viel viel
billiger viel viel weniger ssh connection aufmacht der kerl hat mal ubuntu installiert in der vm
ist kein spaß ich weiß es hört sich an wie ausgedacht er hat mal ubuntu installiert in der vm
und langjährig hat er überhaupt nichts gemacht es ist einfach schon zwei jahre her gewesen so nach
dem motto als er ubuntu in der vm installiert hat das war alles das hat er auch zugegeben ich weiß
nicht wie der typ da drauf kommt er hat langjährige linux erfahrung und ubuntu installiert ich glaube
sogar jetzt ist ich glaube die haben den sogar genommen später noch allerdings nicht als linux
ich glaube ich glaube den haben die ich glaube den haben die genommen in ich weiß es nicht aber ich
bilde mir einen haben die genommen also mein letzter arbeitgeber für was anderes also er war
auf jeden fall nicht bei uns im linux team weil ich glaube ich bin den dann ich bin in einem
projekt mal wieder begegnet also es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt ausschluss kriterium aber die
erzählen der viel wenn der tag lang ist und die erzählen dem potenziellen arbeitgeber auch viel
wenn der tag lang ist da muss halt immer gucken was der da treibt ja und schon gibt es gute date
time apis eigentlich nicht mir fällt glaube ich keine programmiersprache ein die eine richtig
gute in der standard library eine richtig gute date time implementierung hat ich mein
funktionieren tun sie alle irgendwie besser halt nicht funktionieren der time ist immer äußerst also
generell alles was mit zeit zonen zeit und und lokalisieren sowas ist immer super super anfällig
ich bin nicht entwickler ich bin nicht entwickler ich bin hauptberuflicher senior
five hat linux engineer aber ich meine ich interessiere mich halt dafür und wenn du mal
in die stream history guckst wirst du sehen wir haben auch schon ein paar sachen hier im stream
programmiert ja mir fällt keine programmiersprache ein ja moment wir reden ja nicht an moment wir
reden nicht wir reden jetzt ja nicht über zusatz libraries da gibt es ein paar gescheite wir reden
ja jetzt über standard libraries geschichten also chat welche programmiersprache hat eurer
meinung nach die beste default date time implementierung also ich würde so spontan
sagen es ist tatsächlich dort nett aber gar nicht so sehr weil die so easy to usen ist oder so
fehlerfrei benutzt werden kann was mir an der dort nett implementierung gefällt ist dass die
alles hat was man braucht das haben die meisten anderen programmiersprache nicht da fehlt ja dann
irgendein timestamp typ da fehlt ja dann irgendein ordentlicher duration typ da kannst du nicht
richtig rechnen mit mit durations oder timespans und da kannst du da sachen nicht richtig hinzufügen
ich habe schon ich habe schon die ford date implementierung erlebt da hast du dann gesagt
at minutes 120 und dann hat er dann quasi ist er overflowed und am ende stand dann irgendwie die
minuten auf auf keine ahnung 45 oder so ganz weird weird weird zeug graben. python hat mir
auch nicht gut gefallen da habe ich da haben wir python haben wir tatsächlich was gemacht mit date
time genau ja den timer haben wir selbst programmiert hier oben das ist unter der haube
ist das ein plugin in python für die für diese statusleistung und da mussten wir auch mit date
time sachen arbeiten und da habe ich anfälle bekommt bekommen wie python durations handelt
ich bin ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher was genau mich da so geärgert hat bei ich glaube dass du
mit durations nicht richtig rechnen konntest oder dass du am ende durations nicht richtig von von
time abziehen konntest irgendwas war super weird also okay trifft es am besten aber schön war es
nicht deswegen ich würde auch sagen dass dass die dotnet implementierung wirklich ganz gut ist
mittlerweile die ist super die ist die super verteilt du hast in dotnet hast du date time
du hast date time offset dann hast du timestamp geschichten so du hast bestimmt 7 8 verschiedene
einstiegspunkte was date time angeht in dotnet timespan aber wenn man das kennt ist es ziemlich
komplett und lässt sich gut verwenden wenn wenn die auch echt natürlich die die üblichen probleme
haben die date time libraries so haben so so zum beispiel wusstet ihr habe ich letztens in
einem konferenztalk gesehen wo sie das schweden ich weiß recycle story dass schweden das einzige
land war auf der welt das sind 30 februar hatte und das müssen alle date time libraries
berücksichtigen die historische daten ausgeben können machen sie natürlich nicht welche
programmiersprache würde dir eigentlich für einen anfänger empfehlen das ist eine exzellente
programmiersprache dazu habe ich ein video gemacht und zwar du kannst es entweder bei mir gucken oder
bei ihm gucken mit algorithmen verstehen damals damals hieß er noch so bei mir gibt es das gibt
es das auch irgendwo da haben wir ein video zu gemacht wobei ich sagen muss ich gehe nicht so
ganz d'accord mit den sachen wie der florian im video sagt denn ja das da denn er meint dass c++
gut ist wenn man bestimmte sachen machen möchte zum zum einstieg ich bin der meinung c++ ist der
beste weg leute zu verkraulen dass sie nie wieder irgendwas mit programmieren am hut haben wollen
das video fand ich so semi ja da kann ich auch nichts machen warum java muss dabei sein ich
habe dort net dabei java und dort net bringt da nichts beides reinzupacken ich persönlich finde
auch dort net uns die schaben viel angenehmer als java was ich bisher gesehen habe also ich würde
dir empfehlen ganz ehrlich bist du auch noch da als falls du noch da bist bg superiority ich würde
javascript empfehlen zum einstieg genauso wie sonny das gemacht hat javascript also du kannst
natürlich auch mit python oder so was anfangen aber ich würde dir javascript empfehlen wenn du
noch gar keine vorkenntnisse hast und wenn du auch noch gar keine idee hast in welcher richtung du
was machen willst dann würde ich dir javascript empfehlen weil aus aus aus einem kund javascript
hat mit abstand die geringste einstiegs würde um javascript ein bisschen rumzubasteln brauchst du
ein browser den hast du eh schon und du brauchst ein texteditor nach möglichkeit nicht notepad
sondern installiert wichtel studio code da hast du super javascript css html support out of the
box du brauchst einen browser und das war es das ist die mit abstand niedrigste einstiegshürde
und es hat auch einen zweiten vorteil noch zwei weitere vorteil die mir so spontan einfallen das
erste ist du findest für javascript du findest für javascript überall tutorials und anleitungen
und und blogposts und sowas und das dritte ist wenn du wenn du das im zuge von frontend oder
webseiten das muss ja nicht webseiten ja frontend anwendung lernst da siehst du visuell dass im
browser was passiert und für deine weitere entwickler karriere falls du sowas anstrebst
man kommt an frontend sachen nicht vorbei selbst wenn du der krasseste kobold mainframe ok die
kommen vielleicht dran vorbei aber an ein bisschen frontend kommt eigentlich niemand vorbei und dann
wenn du wenn du dir das ein bisschen angeguckt hast und so ungefähr eine idee hast was du mal
gerne machen würdest dann sucht man sich ja das raus was am besten passt ich würde beispielsweise
nie auf die idee kommen sp 32 mit javascript zu programmieren sp 32 sind so kleine so kleine
microcontroller wurde beispielsweise ein gutes beispiel dafür temperatursensor dranhängen
kannst und das dann über wlan auswerten kannst so wie viel temperatur ist es hier luftfeuchtigkeit
oder sowas in der richtung das würde ich im leben nicht mit javascript programmieren auch wenn es
glaube ich javascript interpreter firmware es gibt zum flashen dafür würde ich nicht machen ja da
würde ich würde ich mir was anderes anschauen in dem fall ist es halt eigentlich nur c++ oder
ich würde beispielsweise auch keine windows desktop anwendung bauen mit javascript oder
ich würde kein linux command line tool bauen mit javascript ich weiß ich weiß es geht alles aber
da gibt es bessere sachen für und dementsprechend wenn du dann weißt was du machen willst kannst
du dir ja raussuchen was gut dazu passt ja also wenn du schon was bestimmtes hast was zu programmieren
willst ist natürlich noch besser also dann schon was bestimmtes also wenn du was bestimmtes hast
ist noch besser das motiviert meistens auch wenn man sieht dass man eben das was man eh schon im
kopf vor hat im besser umsetzen kann wir haben neues emot übrigens community ge das seid ihr
chat welche davon ist chain law kann mich nicht entscheiden und mal ganz davon abgesehen du kannst
mit webassembly noch nicht mal frontend geschichten gescheit machen das ist zur unterstützung von
frontend sachen gut aber ich glaube du kannst aus webassembly mittlerweile noch nicht mal sagen wir
mal den button klicken in javascript button klicken weil du brauchst nach wie vor javascript
meinung zum neuen db streckenagent woher weiß ich denn dass die neuen db streckenagent habe ich
muss mal gucken vielleicht habe ich den auch gar nicht an der was für games werden wir dann hier
empfohlen db streckenagent doch habe ich habe ich ja ach ja natürlich der ist neu aber der ist
doch schon seit bestimmt einem monat neu oder dass es hat ein paar sachen gehabt die mich genervt
haben aber das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr das wusste ich vor einem monat vielleicht ich
glaube ich habe bei irgendwas das problem dass er die ich glaube du kannst nicht mehr so viel
vor und zurück scrollen wie früher das war ein problem und er refresh die zeiten bei zügen nicht
wenn du einfach nur die app also wenn du einfach nur den zugriff recht das hat er gecashed und
ruft sich neu ab dementsprechend wenn du einfach nur guckst zug aufmachst guckst ob verspätung
hat zug aufmachst ob es kurz geht nicht du musst tatsächlich die suche neu starten das ging mir
auch auf den keks warum das dort keiner gemerkt hat ist mir schleierhaft max ans trinken erinnern
ja würde ich gerne ich habe aber leer getrunken ich habe nichts mehr da wenn ich weiter ans
trinken erinnert muss ich runter gehen und mir neue neues trinken holen wo bloß habe mein master
studium bereich lebensmittel und ingenieurswesen abgeschlossen aber festgestellt dass ich in dem
bereich keinen spaß habe würde mich noch gerne richtung ok ich gehe ich habe eh durch ich gehe
ich gehe mir schnell was holen da bin ich wieder ich habe mir jetzt einfach ein bisschen leidungswasser
ins glas gemacht also aber mein master studium bereich lebensmittel und ingenieurswesen
abgeschlossen ist ja richtig feifert gibt es bestimmt nicht so viele die das packen aber
festgestellt dass ich in dem bereich keinen spaß habe würde mich noch gerne richtung it weiter
bilden hast du paar tipps wie ich das am besten anstelle denkst du ein quereinstieg ist da irgendwie
möglich wer einstieg hast du aktuell so gute chancen wie nie zuvor weil die einfach händeringen
leute suchen und dementsprechend natürlich auch nicht mehr so wählerisch sind also ich denke mal
deine besten chancen sind wenn du vielleicht überschneidungen hast mit deinem ja fach wie
nennt man das also mit mit deinen vorkenntnissen ja wenn du wenn du irgendwie was findest was
sich überschneidet dass dir das hier irgendwie was bringt was du schon gemacht hast ohne dass
mir dafür jetzt ein konkrete konkrete beispiel einfallen könnte was das was das ist aber es
gibt ja vielleicht irgendwelche unternehmen die generell leute aus dem bereich suchen und
dort braucht es auch oftmals welche die sich mit it und mit dem eigentlichen ja fachlichen thema
auskennen sowas wäre es natürlich gut ansonsten schwer zu schwer zu sagen gibt es dann irgendwelche
bereiche die dir besonders zusagen weil so ganz allgemein ist das schwer zu sagen es gibt glaube
ich in keinem anderen keine anderen richtungen so viele subrichtungen wie man wie in der it ich
meine die grundsätzliche unterscheidung zwischen selbst die grundsätzliche unterscheidung so
zwischen eher entwickeln oder eher so im admin bereich die ist ja auch ziemlich aufgeweicht
worden die letzten jahre über also ja also es wäre schon mal nicht schlecht zu wissen was sich so
prinzipiell interessiert dann lieber mittlerweile echt nur pures javascript ich bin in halben
stunde weg heute nicht außerdem finde ich dort netz zu nice um das mal kurz in 30 min abzuhandeln
da machen wir einen eigenen stream zu und gucken uns mal die sachen an ich habe letztens ein video
zugeguckt über die neuen features von dort netz beziehungsweise von sie schaft 12 glaube ich war
ganz nice dinger dabei aber auch ein paar wo ich mir gedacht habe halbherzig und auch ein paar wo
ich mir gedacht habe muss es sein wie weit bin ich eigentlich mit dem chat hintendran man alles
andere ist blotet aber nächsten stream dann oder halt einen der nächsten streams über technik
sachen machen ja man hat so einen tipp wie man sich wenn befehle merken kann ja ich habe einen
tipp wie man sich wenn befehle merken kann tatsächlich du musst dir die logik dahinter
überlegen wenn man hat so ein bisschen eine eigene sprache zum beispiel ja mein timer ist abgelaufen
zum beispiel ja machen wir mal ein wimmel auf und schreiben jetzt mal irgendwas hin kacke und
jetzt stell dir mal vor ich möchte kacke zu was anderem austauschen und das fällt mir jetzt erst
ein es gibt leute die würden jetzt sowas hier machen das ist natürlich ziemlich lahm so dann
gibt es leute die sind schon ein bisschen advance da die würden sowas hier machen f und dann k und
dann k drücken um zu dem ersten vorkommen zu dir von dem von dem zeichen zu springen ich würde
tippen ci anführungszeichen moment warum geht das nicht das geht nach vorne das geht nicht nach
hinten ok wie wieder wieder was gelernt da ist perfekte demonstration also ich glaube jetzt hast
du gemerkt wie man sich wenn shortcuts merken kann also worauf ich worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte
ist wenn shortcuts haben eine gewisse gewisse grammatik dahinter wenn du jetzt hier bist und
drückst zum beispiel ci ups ci anführungszeichen da kannst du dir merken dass das heißt change
inner und dann das zeichen was du drückst ci anführungszeichen bedeutet change inner das
zwischen anführungszeichen so und du wirst sehen das funktioniert damit anderen sachen auch du
kannst auch sagen ci klammer zum beispiel ci klammer und dann schafft er an die stelle rein
also musst du musst du musst eher versuchen so die grammatik hinter den wem kommandos zu verstehen
anstatt für einzelne anwendungszwecke die kommandos stumpf auswendig zu lernen es sind
immer noch ein paar sachen die sind unlogisch aber so kommt man da ganz gut hin wenn man wenn man
versucht sich zu merken für was die einzelnen subteile von so einem befehl bestehen und sich
das dann zusammenbauen wie man es braucht also dass du dir nicht merkst es ist ci anführungszeichen
und ci klammer sondern dass du weißt okay es heißt quasi change inner und dann zwischen dem zeichen
was du zwischen den zwei zeichen dass du angibst ansonsten mit dem cheat sheet und so ein paar
basics lernen es ist ja gar nicht so viel was man braucht im wem was man sich standardmäßig merken
muss du musst dir merken wie du was schließt beziehungsweise was speicherst da gibt es ja auch
drei varianten also zumindest die mir zu einfallen doppelpunkt x doppelpunkt wq oder schiff zz warum
schiff zz überhaupt ein ding ist verstehe ich nicht das ist wahrscheinlich echt nur für echte
echte hackermans die wir mit schiff zz schließen und speichern warum das geht verstehe ich nicht
terminal tagen oder sowas und ansonsten kannst du dir einfach die teile rauspicken die du öfters
brauchst und dann ist gut also ich habe ich meine ich mir fällt aus dem kopf auch nicht so viel ein
wir fällen die sachen für selection ein also quasi zeile selekten teile selekten oder oder
vertikal selekten das ist immer irgendeine kombination aus shift vv oder control v dann
merke ich mir change inner für irgendwelche sachen dann merke ich mir g und gg für hoch
und runter springen und groß und ganz war es glaube ich schon bestimmt ein paar sachen die
mir nicht einfallen die ich aber automatisch mache habe ich noch nie was gehört heißt nix
aber irgendwelche ui um ui zu designen erinnert mich fast schon ein bisschen an windows forms
kenne ich ich habe früher sogar mal ein plugin für browser verwendet bin ich aber weg davon
bekommen weil man den browser am besten per maus bedient es war schon ganz cool links
öffnen zu können mit shortcuts und so ansonsten also nee gar nicht gar nicht wir haben ja im
stream schon das ein oder andere embedded zeug gemacht aber immer nur c++ wenn es nicht anders
geht und spätestens wenn du microcontroller zeug geht dann kommst du da halt oft nicht vorbei
gerade beim esp 32 ist es nach wie vor das beste wenn du einen wenn du einen suchst der
viel im better zeug macht dann musst du den mod gefragt hier über der message der kennt sich damit
aus ja also bei go habe ich daytime kriege ich oftmals anfälle also beispielsweise es fängt ja
schon bei so simplen sachen an wie bei go sleep fünf mal seconds aber second aber aber aber
time second selbst kannst du dann wiederum nicht richtig verwenden ganz ganz wirres zeug und die
durations in go sind auch wir da kann ich tatsächlich gar nichts sagen ich kenne das
in java nicht c++ ist nicht mal das geht ja noch irgendwie c++ der native c++ way was mit
time zu machen ist chrono und ich weiß nicht ob ich schon mal die chrono api benutzen müsstest
in c++ aber ich habe echt keine ahnung in welcher geistigen umnachtung die sich da wieder im c++
gremium befunden haben die waren wahrscheinlich auch nebenbei auf einer usb gremiumssitzung auf
was andere ist sonst kommst du nicht auf die idee also das ist echt immer super super wird
zeitzonen sind immer eklig gerade weil es im zweifelsfall auch doppeldeutig sein kann was
gibt es für gute go projekte überlegen wir das anzuempfehlen ja dann bau doch mal ein ordentliches
command line tool selfcontained binary weil es ja mit go wo für go ja geradezu gemacht ist
such dir irgendwas aus für command line tool muss gar nichts sonderlich tolles sein und dann
implementiere command line parsing mit einer ordentlichen library lernst du auch schon gibt
zwei größere für go mit denen man das macht das eine ist wie heißt auch wir sogar vergessen es
gibt zwei größere command line parse libraries also command line und argument parsing und so für
sein das cobra glaube ich ja cobra und dann gibt es noch ein anderes cobra und viper irgendwie so
gibt es zwei zwei größere standard library geht auch halbwegs klar aber ja manchmal ist
da go ein bisschen umständlich dann guckst du noch an wie man gescheite terminal ausgabe macht
tabellen formatieren und habe und sowas ja ordentliche hilfetext da kannst du dir schon
mal die libraries angucken ansonsten keine ahnung was ein gutes umfangreiches go projekt ist wo du
mehrere aspekte brauchst also vielleicht willst du ja auch sowas machen wie irgendwie jason
abfragen jason parsen keine ahnung fällt mir gerade nichts ein ich benutze go eigentlich nur
für command line projekte und da finde ich es ganz gut mittlerweile meine das schöne an go ist dass
du komplett selbst contain binaries hast das ist das ist mit abstand das beste an go ich weiß viele
leute mögen an go unter anderem noch dass es meist für die meisten sachen genau ein weg gibt wie man
was macht wobei mich persönlich das ein bisschen nervt weil ich den go weg an manchen stellen nicht
so schön finde zum beispiel was ich nicht mag ist das go wenn du bei go und schreibst musst du
so machen hier kecke else if else so und ich persönlich finde das richtig eklig das so zu
formatieren aber man muss das machen in go weil es kompiliert sonst einfach nicht um das um mb3
mache ich ein riesen riesen bogen ich habe ja ich habe ja vor ein paar jahren schon video gemacht
das super als kreativ komplett kreative bankrotterklärung finde diese ganze reboot
geschichte wenn man das erste auch noch ganz gut spielen konnte und war sonntag wirklich ein
bisschen was eigenständiges was dann auch erfolg hat aber ich finde es so auch so ultra aufguss
langweilig doof einfach nur noch mittlerweile und mir gefällt auch das gameplay von den remakes
nicht weil das einfach sehr wie haben wir es letztens gehabt ab eben lastig ist doch doch es
gibt ein einfaches if ich das war jetzt so ein beispiel wie du mit einem elze von dem else
schreibst das finde ich halt nicht finde ich persönlich finde das keine schöne sonntags ich
finde die sonntags ok chatte frage frage an euch das habe ich schon mal gemacht welche sonntags
check welche sonntags also so viele leute die zwei besser finden wirklich zwei aber
else in neuer zeile kannst du nicht machen dann kompiliert gar nicht ok das hätte ich das hätte
ich gar nicht gedacht aber ich also ich finde das viel angenehmer als das untere aber so sind
die geschmeck haben wir hatten ja sehr viele auswahlmöglichkeiten also mir gefällt das obere
besser ja ja natürlich kommt es da ich gewohnt bin natürlich ist das ist immer gewonnen gewöhnungs
also das ist halt das ist halt das vor und nachteil von go zugleich du musst dich halt
dran halten auch eine sache die ich überhaupt nicht mag in go ist diese geschichte mit an
variablen weil es kommt so oft vor dass man einfach mal irgendwas ausprobieren will und
da geht das nicht dann willst du was anderes ausprobieren kommentiert das eine schnell aus
und das andere und dann kommt auch an just variablen ja da muss der immer was davor schreiben
ich weiß es geht bei imports auch das finde ich mega nervig ich verstehe warum die das machen ja
und ich glaube denen sogar dass es dass es unterm strich dazu führt dass das was dann an an code
drin ist insgesamt und am strich besser ist aber es ist es nervt mich beim entwickeln extrem in
go diese sachen aber trotzdem insgesamt richtig ist plexer genau das denke ich mir auch warum
kann man nicht einfach sagen ignoriert das und gut es liegt vielleicht daran dass go keine
debug und release builds hat in dem sinn gibt es gibt es ja in go nicht aber aber dafür fände ich
das auch sinnvoll ja man wenn man eine option setzen könnte und sagen hey kommt solange ich
solange ich im debug modus bin dann lasst mich das halt machen aber dass da gab da gab es ja
sogar mal ein go fork deswegen hat keiner benutzt aber das wollen sie partout nicht aber ich kann
zumindest sagen go ist eine super geschichte gerade wenn du im cloud umfeld unterwegs bist
oder generell auch wenn du wenn du viel mit linux unter am arbeiten bist go lohnt sich gerade wenn
man mal kleine kommandozeilen sachen braucht ist so einfach top es gibt nichts was so einfach auf
alle systeme zu deployen ist wie ein go binary das geht einfach ja das ist echt so c++ für den
einstieg und du bist erst mal weg rage quit bett ge machst du dann ja das stimmt auch wieder aber
trotzdem ich finde allein schon durch die niedrige einstiegshürde ist ja was gibt das beste
prinzipiell würde ich dir recht geben dass du viele sachen transferieren kannst so von den basics
her ja und if schleifen bis go to dass du sagst dass du sachen von von wie macht man eine schleife
wie ein if man macht man gliedert man was in eine funktion aus wann rappt man das am besten irgendwo
rein so die sachen das kann man gut transferieren zwischen unterschiedlichen programmier sprachen
oftmals ist es ja auch im handling und und in der benahmung parallelen zu erkennen ja ja zum beispiel
kann man in javascript array filtern mit filter in sich schaden mit wer und solche sachen aber
man hat sich da schon ein bisschen dran gewöhnt und dass man kann vieles transferieren das stimmt
schon also man merkt auch jemand der schon erfahrungen hat in 1 2 vielleicht drei sprachen
wenn der sich dann oder sagen wir mal mindestens in einer sprache wenn der sich dann eine andere
sprache anguckt geht es in der regel deutlich schneller sich einzuarbeiten und anzugucken als
wenn du noch gar keine ahnung hast und was auch den riesen vorteil ist wenn du 1 2 programmier
sprachen kannst du kannst eigentlich fast instant source code lesen und das ist das worauf sie
oftmals ankommen wenn du einfach nur willst alter warum geht in der scheiß net und du guckst nach
vielleicht ist es auch ein source projekt auf github du willst kurz nach was macht es eigentlich dann
ist es in java zum beispiel ja ich habe sehr viel java code lesen müssen als ich hier meine für
für mein elektroauto gebaut habe gibt es eigentlich issues keine issues keine issues bekannt das ist
zwar in dort net aber ich habe sehr viel java gelesen weil die fiat android app die ist in java
programmiert und ich habe einfach das apk entpackt und mir angeguckt was fiat da macht an vielen
stellen und ich habe noch nie in meinem leben java programmiert mehr als drei zeilen und ich
konnte es ohne probleme lesen das ist halt echt der vorteil davon in ein paar sprachen kannst ich
mag windows forms für einfachen kram immer noch du machst eigentlich back in der forms und baue
eine react web für spilling das wäre was wo ich echt bock drauf hätte wenn ich es machen müsste
ich würde es nicht in react machen ich würde so lange rum meckern bis ich irgendwie was anderes
verwenden darf aber da hätte ich ehrlich gesagt bock drauf morgen kann ich wieder ein paar helden
schatz zusammen wurschteln ich auch bock drauf sowas mache ich einfach gern das problem ist doch
wenn du c++ meisterst hast du viel problem mit anderen sprachen weil dann dein gehirn so kaputt
ist und denkt dass die c++ weise normal ist und dich fragst alter warum ist es denn in jeder
anderen sprache nicht möglich template konstexpr standard filter iterator begin end zu schreiben
oder sowas und dann fragst du dich alter wie macht man eine schleife in c sharp wie geht das
man kann doch nicht einfach da hinschreiben und dann funktioniert das nee das kann nicht sein
und ich kann doch jetzt nicht auch einfach ein array filtern mit einer methode die auf dem
array drauf ist und nicht standard filter map iter begin end ähnliche lambda synthax und dann
compiler fehler kriegen das geht nicht also ich glaube du bist komplett durch wenn du c++ gemeistert
hast ich habe die beste das beste beispiel für scheiß c++ synthax gefunden gerade zufällig nebenbei
auf dem zweiten bildschirm ok pass mal auf ich gebe zu es ist neun jahre alt aber ich glaube es
ist immer noch genauso beschissen ok der bringt in c sharp beispiel guck war filtert elements
elements wer element ist ist erfüllt diese bedingung ja ein ganz normales link query in
c sharp du hast ein array elements oder eine liste elements oder halt irgendein enumerable
elements und da filterst du alle elemente raus die eben hier drauf wo wo ihr true rauskommt am
ende so pass mal auf was war auf c++ das ist so schlecht das tut weh das ist so schlecht guckt
euch das an was ist das denn was ist das was haben die sich ausgedacht was ist bei denen kaputt im
kopf ich meine ernsthaft das passt was ist das mann was was und auch diese komische synthax hier
oben schon wieder ok ich glaube das ist einfach listen initialisierung das ist das geht glaube
ich noch in ordnung wer in diesem c++ gremium hat sich allen ernstes gedacht
ja genau so genau so muss das sein so ist das gut weil guckt euch das mal an standard copy
if bedeutet wahrscheinlich so viel wie kopiere das element in in ein ziel array wenn die bedingung
war es so schlimm ist das jetzt war das ist das ist horror natürlich das ist mega schlimm dieses
eine beispiel für sich genommen in dieser einen zeile nur dieser eine fall ja aber es ist ja in
c++ alles so so also das heißt wahrscheinlich so viel wie kopiere nur die elemente die auf
die bedingung matchen so das ist typischer c++ schwachsinn also hier vector begin vector end
standard back inserter niemand der einfach nur sein vector filtern will kommt auf die idee
dass das überhaupt existiert ich anfälle wenn ich sowas sehe und die lambda synthax dann allein
auch schon das gibt es ja dann auch noch mit einem und hier dazwischen und mit einem gleich
dazwischen das ist die frage ob das quasi closure referenzen also in der closure das
referenziert oder kopiert und guck mal guck mal hier unten genau das ist es
und die empfehlung ist jetzt ok das ist die go antwort das ist die go antwort ja die das ist
das ist die typische go antwort das brauchen wir alles nicht das ist die go antwort eigentlich
weil in go gibt es ja auch nicht in go sagen die alle wie du willst du willst in array filtern
just loop der wird nicht gefiltert loop und if wer braucht schon irgendwie einen filter oder
dann wäre oder sonst was das loop und if 10 plus 20 es geht weiter was ist das für
eine synthax schon wieder man was zum teufel 10 plus plus shit ernsthaft seriously 10 plus plus
premium war es nicht möglich einfach auf vector eine fucking filter methode einzubauen was ist
das problem daran mensch gibt weg gibt vector eine filter methode ich meine die 10 plus plus
standard library hat was fünf collections oder so kann auch nicht so schwierig schwierig sein
denen eine filter methode zu verpassen jetzt musst du vector pipe nach views filter wer
kommt auf diese idee mann der nächste kommt an mit boost ich brauche boost um ein fucking
array zu filtern alter deckel type elements value type konst und elm selbstverständlich alles klar
der normale reicht mir schon er hat erreicht ich brauche ich brauche den hier wir müssen wir
möchten da festhalten der typ an den array und möchte einfach nur die elemente rausfüllen
die einem bestimmten kriterium entsprechen ja und das ist ernsthaft es wird ja es ist
alter es wird ja immer schlimmer umso weiter ich hier runter scrolle ok der macht das eklige
beispiel jetzt generic dass es überall drauf funktioniert dann frage ich mich doch warum ist
so was nicht in der standard library drinnen warum ist es nicht ich meine ernsthaft die 10
plus plus standard library hat fünf collection typen oder so die verwendet werden was was haben
die denn die haben vector die haben ihre komische hashmap die haben die haben vector bool was
beide way nicht vector ist wer sie jetzt denkt vector bool und vector int wäre das gleiche
nein ein vector vector bool ist was anderes die haben zwei verschiedene dictionaries die
haben hashmap und irgendwie frag mich nicht binary tree hashmap oder sowas die haben es
gibt ja nicht mal viele ja guck mal das ist alles das ist alles array vector dq forward
list list so dann gibt es noch gibt es noch einen stack q set multi set map das ist ja
nicht viel es ist jetzt ja nicht so als reden wir über 150 container warum jetzt jetzt ernsthaft
ich verstehe warum können die nicht einfach weil moment kurz musik zur beruhigung warum
können die nicht einfach ich meine einen container filtern auf eine bedingung so wie
man es hier das ist eines der häufigsten sachen das ist so häufig dass javascript
das auch einfach eingebaut hat mittlerweile bei javascript machst du array filter und
warum kann man guck mal es gibt es gibt es gibt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 16
container typen von denen man wahrscheinlich öfters drei oder vier verwendet warum warum
macht man nicht einfach eine filter methode für diese container und gut ist wo ist das problem
man kann ja sowas meinetwegen zusätzlich noch anbieten dass das damit unter der haube
implementiert warum nicht einfach eine filter mit den stahlen weg aber anstatt das zu machen
aber anstatt das zu machen baut man sowas komisches hier wieder warum gibt es nicht
vector punkt filter ich verstehe es hat sicherlich irgendeinen grund aber bestimmt
nichts was man nicht umgehen könnte und wenn es sonderfälle gibt das ordentlich beschreiben wie
sich das verhält und gut ist ich verstehe es einfach nicht jeder stimmt in dort net
passenden timer zu finden ist ist auch beknackt es gibt ja noch neuen timer jetzt mittlerweile
in dort net es gibt jetzt in dort net noch periodic timer das ist der neueste timer weil
fünf timer klassen haben noch nicht gereicht wir brauchen jetzt eine fünfte timer klasse
und es ist die erste timer klasse wo dort net sagt wo microsoft sagt die taugt jetzt und die
ist es kompatibel und was auch immer dafür hat sie viele features der anderen timer nicht ich
würde einfach vorschlagen mal verwendet irgendeine ordentliche timer library von github anstatt die
timer aus dem dort net framework aber immerhin ist es nicht so abartig wie c++ gibt es die
sounds irgendwo du meinst du meinst dass hier ja das gibt es das ist aus irgendeinem anime wo
bestimmt die weibs unter uns wissen wie der heißt das ist von einer japanischen text to speech
engine was ich habe generieren lassen das gibt es nirgendwo es gibt es nur bei mir im soundboard
ich weiß gar nicht ob sie text to speech engine noch gibt wir brauchen ein keck ja brauchen wir
unbedingt so genug aufgeregt jetzt jetzt ich muss mal kurz ok sorry leute ich muss mal kurz
meine uhr anziehen ich muss mal kurz puls pulse check pulse check leider leider habe ich mich
jetzt schon wieder abgeregt das war 71 ok ich bin super entspannt ist schon wieder vorbei vorher
hatte ich wahrscheinlich 65 oder so was 70 sind jetzt nur noch 69 69 puls 68 c++ 67 ok es geht
weiter runter es muss mich schon ein bisschen aufgeregt haben so hi chat ich habe bald physik
abschlussprüfung habt ihr irgendwelche tipps und tricks ich bin so nervös ja ich habe tipps
mach alte abschlussprüfung machst du denn schon alte abschlussprüfung mache alte abschlussprüfung
einfach bestehen genau just 5 hat ja in den just vorher einfach bestehen macht alte abschlussprüfung
da bist du auch deutlich sicherer danach wie die ihk so fragen stellt du musst also das ist
wirklich pflicht um eine prüfung halbwegs auf die reihe zu bekommen du musst alte abschlussprüfung
machen also jemand denn ein halbes jahr sich vorbereitet oder halbes jahr der sich also jemand
der sich drei vier wochen vorbereitet mit alten abschlussprüfung was ist jemand der die ausbildung
drei jahre lang gemacht hat derjenige mit drei bis vier wochen abschlussprüfung vorbereitung
schreibt die bessere prüfung ja das kann ich das ganze ist was ist allmann style indentation
ach so ich dachte das heißt elmen nicht allmann ich habe gedacht es ist für alle die besonders
pingelig sind oder so dann mag ich allmann style bin gar nicht auf dem laufen bist du noch bei der
neuen firma ja ich die probezeit auch schon vorbei und ich bin immer noch da sehe ich auch so geht
das eigentlich im dornett umfeld ich weiß nicht was du meinst weil das ich bin mit dem chat so
weit hintendran das war noch vor meinem vor meiner c++ eskalation was das
aha ich checks jetzt nicht so ganz auf die schnelle wenn man pointe in der lupe wendet
wird immer die gleiche variable genommen verstehe ich trotzdem nicht müssen wir uns demnächst mal
angucken muss mir mal erklären dann tippe ich das mal ein oder prüfen das aus hab keck piano schon
vorbereitet es muss jetzt aber noch in irgendein wichtig mode fähiges ding gebracht werden cg
tatsächlich also ich muss sagen gute zähler im breeze lassen sich nice benutzen ffmpeg zum
beispiel ffmpeg ist kompliziert weil ein bisschen legacy shit aber muss ehrlich sagen ffmpeg lässt
sich in c echt nice benutzen man sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnt hat herrscher für den
ich habe viele gute gut programmierte cpc library schon gesehen c++ weniger die einfach angenehm
zu benutzen waren er zählt wenn man vieles zusammen macht vom scratch machen muss ziemlich
aufwändig weil es halt wenig was heißt wenig nichts im endeffekt eingebaut hat und manches
halt auch sehr umständlich nur zur hand haben ist ja state musste immer beispielsweise dann
irgendwie als void pointer irgendwo durch passen und sowas oder irgendeinen strakt dem du nichts
machen das durch passen von einer methode zur anderen aber insgesamt also ich habe schon vieles
angenehme in c gesehen in c++ selten jetzt c macros gehen ja irgendwo noch hält sich ja in
grenzen aber c++ templates ist halt echt ich finde c++ templates ist eines der besten und gleichzeitig
beschissensten sachen dieser c++ gibt du kannst mit c++ templates prinzipiell enorm coole sachen
machen leider ist es so übertrieben mittlerweile an vielen stellen und es verbessert wirklich nicht
die compiler meldung wenn was kaputt ist also mir fällt keine andere programmier sprache ein
außer c++ wo ich beispielsweise zur compile time checken kann ob wenn ich an eine methode
oder eine funktion ein string übergebe aber besser gesagt character array übergebe ob der
größer ist als 15 zeichen mir fällt keine sprache ein der ich das machen kann runtime
checks klar kannst du in jeder sprache machen aber zur compile time checken ob der string der
übergeben wird größer als 15 zeilen ist und dann eine compiler meldung schmeißen da fällt mir keine
sprache außer c++ ein in der das geht in c++ ist es natürlich super eklig wie das funktioniert
das geht nur mit templates konstexpr und irgendwie weird champ pick some shit aber es geht dass das
ist also da sieht man man kann schon enorm coole sachen machen mit rust macros könnte man es
vielleicht irgendwie machen ja was ist ein kritikpunkt an react ich habe keine kritikpunkte
an react ich kenne mich mit react nicht groß aus bisher was ich von react gesehen habe hat es mich
auch nicht so angesprochen mit ihrer html in javascript geschichte letztendlich machen das
ja viele webframework so aber die lassen dich wenigstens html in html schreiben und nicht dass
du es dann von hand direkt rappen musst in javascript und dann auch sachen umbenennen musst
die halt in javascript keywords sind und sowas es ist alles gewöhnungssache ansonsten ich kann
nichts schlechtes über react sagen ich habe react schlicht und gerade mikros ausprobiert
ja morgen wird auch bei mir heimschatz verwurstet habe ich schon richtig bock drauf patchy airflow
kenne ich gar nicht was ist das ich muss jetzt gleich ins bett leute noch irgendwas beantworten
was gerade jemand gepostet hat wo ist das denn ja ich kenne eins aber das will ich nicht empfehlen
achso ja diese spezielle sache weiß ich im park glf max es gibt eine coole seite wie
set servers da kannst du sachen cool cloud native hands-on plattform für der forms ach
ja cool speichere ich mir mal fände ich mega nice wenn es noch mehr so sachen wie set servers gibt
das macht macht richtig bock und es ist gut das stream content und alle lernen was bei
uns finde ich nice muss ich mir mal angucken warum macht er das dreimal auf gerade wenn
das ist richtig geprägt gerade und was da bin aus ok was auch immer subscription herrscher
herrscher ja ich bin gleich im bett habe ich irgendwas ich wollte noch irgendwas beantworten
gerade vor schauen chat gucken ab das blick sah da was gefragt was würdest du für ein us für den
kubernetes cluster empfehlen ich will in klasse hauptsächlich für mich zum lernen und basteln
aufsetzen gut ich hätte gesagt neben der menage plattform aber das willst du ja nicht eigentlich
egal eigentlich eigentlich wurscht ich würde nicht sagen also es gibt ja so ein paar kubernetes
distribution sowas wie auch wie heißt das mit mit im mutable konfigs und so
wie ist das nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nix os das meine ich nicht
das meine ich genau das würde ich gern mal ausprobieren aber ich würde sagen das ist zum
einstieg gar nicht so nice weil das ist halt sehr auf eine sache zugeschnitten und dann hast du dann
keine anderen tools und kannst die konflikt nicht richtig abdehnen neben irgendwas neben
irgendwas kannst du bunten nehmen irgendwas und dann legt los lokal ganz ehrlich ich würde ich
würde gar nicht mit einem kopf vollwertigen kubernetes cluster anfangen ich würde mit
minikube anfangen minikube ist ein kubernetes was du dir auf dem lokalen rechner auf einer
lokalen linux kiste installieren kannst unter der haube startet das zwei docker container mit
der kubernetes control plane drin und ein bisschen anderen kram aber einfach zum basteln ist minikube
top kog minikube ist so easy dass du einfach sagt minikube start oder hast du kubernetes
cluster laufen ich habe noch alte docker container laufen das habe ich minikube start beim fertig
das dauert jetzt ein bisschen länger weil ich irgendwie noch was was alles im hintergrund
laufen hatte das ist nichts was du production mäßig betreiben möchtest mit minikube und dadurch
dass es in docker selbst läuft hast du vielleicht ein paar probleme was nicht funktioniert aber
groß und ganz ist gut minikube kube ctl get pods minus a richtet dir auch direkt die connection
zu deinem lokalen cluster ein aber wir haben dann mal hello hello helm app weiß ich nicht
was wir da gemacht haben und wenn du fertig bist sagst du minikube stopp und oder sagst
kannst du auch gleich sagen mini minikube delete ja und dann ist der ganze cluster wieder weg
extremly also zum basteln ist minikube echt beste ja das würde ich empfehlen und jetzt
leute ich gehe ins bett macht's gut wir sehen uns im nächsten stream bis dann
na klar habe ich auch gerade gemacht ich war noch in der vm bis dann